so we analyzed our one-dimensional
collision where we had an object one
moving with some initial velocity object
two also moving some initial velocity
and after the collision we just
arbitrarily said object one is moving
this way and object two was moving that
way we called that our I hat direction
in this collision we assumed that it was
a frictionless surface and there were no
external forces so momentum is constant
now what about energy well we know that
if there's external force if there's no
external forces then in principle there
could be no external work however during
the collision we've established
different types of collisions we said
elastic collision is when we are
assuming that the kinetic energy of the
system that's K system final minus K
system initial is zero the statement
that the kinetic energy is constant we
have an inelastic collision
in which delta k system has decreased
and that can come from some deformation
of the objects during the collision heat
is generated some sound some other
source of energy in which is energy is
always constant but the kinetic energy
the system could diminish and we also
talked about a super elastic collision
and in this type of collision the
kinetic energy of the system has
increased now that's a little bit tricky
in terms of what we're calling our
system but imagine that when these two
objects collided there was some type of
chemicals on it that exploded and so
that there's some chemical energy that
was converted into excessive can extra
kinetic energy so in order to make a
model of our problem we have to
beforehand make some assumptions about
the nature of the collision now for our
particular collision let's assume that
the collision is elastic so we have two
conservation principles we have that the
kinetic energy the system is constant
and we've already said that because
there's no external forces the momentum
the system is constant so now we can
write down our kinetic energy condition
we have m1 v1 now here this can be a
little bit tricky how we're gonna write
this because remember kinetic energy is
a magnitude squared plus one-half m2 the
two initial squared equals one-half m1
v1 final squared plus one-half m2 v2
final squared now because a component
although it can be positive or negative
in one dimension if you square the
component you get the magnitude so I can
also write this equation and I'm going
to divide through by the halves or
cancel all those as one X initial
squared equal to the magnitude squared
plus M to be 2x
initial squared equals and
be 1x final squared plus one-half m2 v2
X final squared
and we've already cancelled all the
halves so we have no half there now
given this equation we'll call this
equation one we can also had our
momentum equation which I'm going to
write down as to m1 the X initial plus
m2v2 X initial equals m1 the 1x final
plus m2 be 2x final reminding us of our
condition of the constancy of momentum
so now if you look at this if we're
given the masses all the M is and we're
also given the initial state of the
system B 2 X initial then we have two
equations and two unknowns and we can
solve algebraically for the 1x final and
V 2 X final and by determining the sout
the signs of these components we can
figure out the actual final state of the
system so this is going to end up
involving the quadratic equation